long long time ago in a land far away
and I was a struggling screenwriter and
I was cranking out original material
that was my thing they figured the only
way I could make my mean I wasn't you
know a pusher and a pounder and a Yeller
and the only way I was gonna make myself
a inevitable was to keep writing and
keep writing and make myself inevitable
through a pile of good to great scripts
and that's pretty much the path the path
I took and I had a great idea about a
war that takes place at the very
beginning of the Civil War it was a
Allan Pinkertons story and I pitched it
all over town I had a good agent at the
time pictured all have a place yeah yeah
good story good story we don't want it
we don't make at the moment the word was
we don't make historical pictures at
that time they were very expensive Hey
costumes Hey
sets locations means you know moolah so
I said fine and then my agent advised me
to move okay fine now we know move on
and I said you know I want to give me a
couple of months cuz I'm gonna write
this anyway I really like this story I
think this is a really good story and I
want to write it he said you're nuts but
okay so I wrote it and I had really
liked it and we tried it again an in
script form and you know got the same
response nobody wanted to do it and I
said okay but I know in my heart it's a
good script so I put it away it was I
forget exactly but eight or nine years
later a producer under very charming
sweet producer by the Wendy diamond was
her name
she calls me up says you know Eric you
know that that Civil War thing you had
do you still have that is is that
available is it available would you
could you send that over at that time
she was working at TNT I was producing
with with another you know I'm strong a
very strong producer at
and at TNT it was TNT that brought back
the epic the historical epic that's part
of what they were into it I guess he was
interested in you know that kind of
material or something so I sent it over
and within I don't know eight or eight
or ten weeks we had a deal
then within eighteen or twenty weeks
they were in pre-production and that's
one of the ones my originals that got
made so how did they have a copy of the
script again I'm sorry
you would sent it out but she wasn't all
she didn't have a copy
she only remembered it she remembered
she had read the whole script back in
the day she was somewhere else yeah she
was somewhere else
doing is doing something else but I
guess the point here for screenwriters
everywhere is all of your original
material has a shelf life it's not that
you give it a shot everybody says no and
you contemplate suicide and you put it
in the closet and carry on right it's
that's not it
the cycles of what they are willing to
purchase or option or consider actually
making the the cycles keep changing at
one point nobody would touch a
historical epic with a ten-foot pole and
some years later that was somebody
looking for one and my my career during
those years at 23 years whatever was my
career as a screenwriter went around
three times you know hot to cold hot to
cold you know three times three full
times and every single time when things
were cooling down things sometimes that
had nothing to do with me you know a
project goes bad and you happen to be
associated with it or it had something
to do with it and then it splashes over
on you people cool for a while every
single time the way I got back in the
game was with a new original screenplay
that's your line of defense you can't be
lazy you cannot be lazy you must
continually be working on original
material
you